las noticias de la economía de france 24
son con daniela blandón
buenas noches daniela hola angela buenas
noches vamos a empezar hablando de sus
temas el hambre se cuadruplicó en el
triángulo del norte de centroamérica si
angela pues mire el programa mundial de
alimentos reveló que el número de
habitantes con inseguridad alimentaria
es decir que no pueden satisfacer sus
necesidades básicas de alimentos pasó de
2 millones a 8 millones en apenas un año
de pandemia en el denominado triángulo
del norte de centroamérica que son el
salvador guatemala y honduras escuchemos
una encuesta y la cantidad de personas
que ahora están pensando en el gran
aumentado 17 8% al 16% ahora y 39
millones de personas en centroamérica si
se hacen los cálculos el 15 por ciento
es mucha gente y si nada cambia creo que
veremos a millones de personas
dirigirlos a eeuu
daniela del senado de méxico aprobó
nuevas normas para su contratación
laboral de qué se trata pues después de
meses de disputas entre el gobierno de
andrés manuel lópez obrador y los
empresarios al final se logró un
consenso para regular la subcontratación
en lugar de prohibir la tanto en el
sector privado como en el público el
primer cambio en la ley es que ahora
prohibir a que las empresas dependan
únicamente del también llamado
outsourcing este mecanismo sólo podrá
ser usado para tareas específicas que no
formen parte de la actividad económica
principal del contratista es decir
angela que no podrán acudir a este tipo
de contrato para delegar tareas
permanentes o esenciales muchos lo
consideran un logro en un país en el que
1 de cada 2 trabajadores es informal y
al menos 5 millones de personas están
subcontratadas
bueno y en europa inició una
investigación sobre la que podría ser la
mayor estafa piramidal con cripto
monedas mire esta es la historia un juez
de la audiencia nacional de españa tiene
en la mira a avistar 2.0 en la que se
prometían rentabilidades de entre el 8%
y el 15% mensual en inversiones con
cripto monedas desde agosto de 2020
varios clientes quisieron retirar sus
fondos sin que la solicitud fuera
atendida lo que hizo esta trama
presuntamente según la autoridad
nacional fue utilizar una parte del
dinero obtenido de los inversores para
pagarles a los otros altos los altos
intereses que habían convenido eso
genera una gran confianza acerca de que
su inversión era muy segura y rentable
de esta manera ellos mismos se animaban
a invertir una mayor cantidad de dinero
con la esperanza de obtener un beneficio
todavía mayor así funcionan las
pirámides pues la cifra de víctimas va
en poco más de 1000 pero se cree que
puede llegar a 32 mil de quienes se
habrían captado ilegalmente hasta 100
millones de euros en más de 30
provincias
muy lamentable y los artistas británicos
se rebelaron contra las aplicaciones de
streaming sí señora lo hicieron en una
carta dirigida al primer ministro
británico o boris johnson y firmada por
156 artistas entre ellos el ex beatle
paul mccartney y chris martin de
coldplay o grupos como the chemical
brothers y massive atack en ella piden
una reforma de las leyes en lo que
tienen que ver con el pago cuando sus
canciones se reproducen en servicios en
línea como spotify la comparación que
hacen es que el beneficio que obtienen
en la radio es del 50 por ciento
mientras que en streaming es de apenas
el 15%
básicamente lo que están diciendo es sí
lo hemos hecho muy bien
a la industria de la música pero estamos
preocupados por la próxima generación de
músicos y cómo se las arreglarán porque
simplemente no ganan lo suficiente para
poder mantener una carrera no eso se ha
puesto de relieve con la falta de
trabajo en vivo debido a la pandemia
frank del bec por favor daniela los
indicadores de la jornada
wall street end se recuperó de una
calidad de dos días en medio de una
semana llena de resultados financieros
las acciones europeas siguieron el mismo
camino aunque le tengo un dato angela la
polémica por la superliga borro el
repunte de juventus del martes y ahora
su acción se derrumbó en casi el 14 por
ciento y en américa latina la bolsa de
buenos aires volvió a terreno positivo
después de que el ministro de economía
regresará de europa y mi parte preferida
para decirle la cifra del día 1.700
millones de dólares esto gano netflix en
el primer trimestre de 2021 en más del
doble de lo reportado hace un año sin
embargo bajó el ritmo de suscripciones y
no alcanzó la meta de 210 millones sus
acciones se desplomaron en casi 8%
daniela gracias con mucho gusto y
ustedes sigan con nosotros en france 24
ya volvemos
[Música]